have you um
you've heard of uh this uh guy who you
have a kind of a similar accent to us
yeah
name is russell brand your ongoing
spiritual journey because you made what
in retrospect still seems like a radical
decision to convert to
oh my islam
russell brad russell is doing a great
job today it seems like a controversial
thing perhaps like um islam has become
more maligned in this sort of
anglophonic west since then
and i really appreciate him uh he veers
you know off on a tangent with the
anything goes you know do what you feel
kind of stuff but boy right now he's
smashing it what what is it in
particular about islam that call to you
and and i did meet russell back in the
day i don't know if he remembers
hopefully not okay so you've met russell
brand there's pictures of him before
like having or reading the quran so i
wanted to ask you have you met him and
has how much does he know have you
gotten a chance well
you probably not but do you know people
who have talked to him about islam or
since he's there in uk right what is it
particularly about the
nature of islam that you feel contacted
you
do you know what um i think
he was with jemima khan for a couple of
years so
uh who's that who's who's
imran khan's ex-wife and she would have
spoken to him about islam
i'm absolutely certain from from that
you know that that he's aware of it as a
world religion
the the big thing for for most people
brother is
the accepting of a faith from god
with stipulations
morality right and wrong
that at some point you have to say no to
yourself
i you know i i think um
you know there was there was a there was
a great
uh
thirst for spirituality out there but
when it comes to saying and people
should not do this and and then there
are things that you must not do
people run
you know the nafs kind of fights you so
i think we should all pray for him i
think he's doing a smashing job of kind
of um fighting uh you know the big
companies and big pharma and may allah
bring him to the truth i mean
so so if you had a chance to sit down
with uh russell brand lauren booth
what would you tell him how would you uh
invite him to go ahead and search more
for the purpose of life while we're here
and to uh look into the quran like you
did to really read it and to really
connect with the creator what message
would you have for russell brandt from
lauren booth do you know what i would
say i'd say
uh
read i know you read so how about
reading the sera of the prophet peace be
upon him by martin ling's
it's written in a story form and you
will know the best of creation
and you will be inspired inspired on
whatever journey you're going on but
know about the prophet now it's time
inshallah